women also have different types of
expenses than men simply because they
are women we actually have to spend more
to keep ourselves attractive and of
course we are attractive because men
want us to be attractive women spend
more on clothes than men women spend
more I got to disagree with you annab
Bay I just I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I
don't understand how you guys spend so
much money on everything I don't think
it's necessary Sanitary products than
men women spend more on beauty products
than men etc etc etc
sorry so if he wants to go 50/50 in the
relationship that just simply shows that
he doesn't want to step into this
masculine role plus he is not a provider
and he might not even be generous so I
don't know if those are the qualities
that you want to work within this
relationship I'm not forcing this upon
you if you are fine with this then
that's absolutely okay no hard feelings
with my
subscribe no